I've learned to schedule personal time
okay so I became a slave to my schedule
yeah and things that were personal
became flexible right so if I wanted to
go to the gym and somebody said can I
have a meeting I would say I would
cancel going to the gym because it's no
big deal yeah
and what ended happening I got sick all
the time and so I learned to schedule
and be very respectful of that schedule
of things that matter to me personally
so for example I'll go to the gym in the
middle of the day
there it is in my calendar Simon's
workout and when somebody calls and says
we'd like to get together with him we
will say I will say anybody will say
because they can see my calendar I'm
sorry he's busy yeah they don't have to
know what I'm doing yeah and sometimes
I'll put a block of time I'll put three
hours or four hours that just says do
not book anything yeah and I make that
time my own time I can watch a movie I
can go for a walk yeah dude everyone
it's my time and I said you really it's
really important for no time yeah it's
really important for me and and I think
one of the things we forget is is the
creativity doesn't happen you can't say
okay be creative now that's right that's
exactly right it happens when you go for
a run or in the car when you're in the
shower it happens at these weird times
but it's not it's not an accident when
it happens because here's how the brain
works which is really fascinating which
is the conscious brain the part of our
brain that is responsible for thinking
that's risk that that that is our
expertise in something that we weigh the
pros and cons we think through the
problem that part of our brain has
access to the equivalent of about two
feet what's that in meters a less than a
meter okay yeah less than a meter if
information around us our subconscious
brains which is responsible for all of
those gut things gut decisions our
subconscious brains have access to the
equivalent of 11 acres of information in
other words every conversation every
book you've read every movie you've seen
gets filed away somewhere but you just
don't have conscious access to it but
it's there and so the value of the
brainstorming is not to solve the
problem it's to ask the question
the value of asking the questions
because your mind isn't going to think
about everything will think ruminate
about everything
it'll only ruminate about things that
are problems in our lives or questions
that have been asked and that's why the
question gets asked in a week later in
the shower you're like that's it I've
got it it's because the mind is still
working on it and you need to give your
mind and so you need to give your mind
time to float go for a run get in the
shower go for a walk you need time go to
a museum your mind needs time to float
and the problem is is we keep filling up
all of the empty space with meetings
with meetings or with our cell phones
yeah so when you're walking from your
house to the bus yeah when you're
sitting on the bus all the gaps that are
that we're not actually at work where we
could just be who recognizes this during
this I mean it happens it'll happen here
let's leave the lights up the I mean I
know exactly what's gonna happen at
these events right because I see it all
the time right you're all here you're
all wonderful and engage with whoever's
on the stage and as soon as there's a
break you're gonna all check in there's
you I see people all the time grazing
they just walk in circles grazing not
all of you but some of you some of you
right and the opportunities are being
missed all over the place number one if
you're checking in with work you're
basically telling your people I don't
trust you right you're telling them I
can't take one day off to go do some
personal enrichment and trust that you
guys can't run the thing without me I'll
check in every email and wait I like
green you know nothing undermines trust
more than your need to feel like you
have to respond to everything number two
you're not meeting each other the
greatest value of this event is not me
it's each other because I know one thing
for sure all of you were willing to
sacrifice time and money to be here
because you wanted to hear a certain
message that you believed in which means
we know one thing about this entire
audience there's a common share of
values and beliefs more than just some
general business industry thing that you
might go to which means all the people
here are potential friends
and and and supporters in hard times you
could meet someone here that in a hard
time you can call them up and say I'm
struggling and they'll say don't worry I
got your back but you're missing the
opportunity to meet new people who share
your values and then of course the best
one is just let it than just letting
your mind wonder those conversations
where ideas can happen is the best thing
in the world
[Music]
[Music]